she's not beating us this time and she  knows it notice her strategy see what  she did  smart she saw that i was here so she's  like let me go to that one because he  hasn't hit that one yet that's extremely  well played oh there's a cop  put your camera down  hey how you doing what's good my friend  how are you i'm holy [ __ ] garyvee  that was [ __ ] amazing  someone just called they were concerned  i guess they thought taking pictures of  the houses i was like because i saw you  i knew you guys i was like did i miss a  stop sign didn't see oh the filming got  it you know who i think might have  called the cops on us  the lady it was a sneaky move by her to  stop us i really respect her game